[Music]
obviously prince has been on everyone's
minds lately since he's passing and one
of the only shows that he ever appeared
on was new girl right and when he when
when he did pass away I saw a lot of
sights replaying that episode and
segments from that episode that Prince
was in how did you get end up getting
Prince on the show because he never did
anything and so I know well he spent you
know a lifetime cultivating mystique and
then one September day three years ago
maybe I got an email from his manager
saying that he liked watching the show
and wanted to come on which was
surprising because they wouldn't have
pegged him as a new girl fan right right
yeah it could seem it's a really great
show and it's a compliment but it can
seem a little random like it did you
know random of obviously a huge
compliment like I was floored and I'm a
huge Prince fan but I was definitely
more than surprised I didn't picture him
watching a sitcom and here's the other
thing right alone he wanted to there was
a party scene that was supposed to be a
party that Prince would really have and
guys got some celebrities for it but
Prince found out that you booked some
people to be at his party who Prince
didn't think would really be at one of
his parties right well I actually didn't
this was sort of you but so yes yeah so
so I'm not sure exactly how you know the
celebrities for the party were chosen
but someone was friends with some of the
Kardashians and had made a phone call
and they had kindly come on to shoot a
little kind of cameo part where they
were at princess party which I didn't
even know about until you know cuz it
kept changing anyway I get there the day
that Prince is supposed to arrive and I
see or I I'm studying my lines and one
of the PAS comes in and she's like I
need all
the sides with the strips and and so she
takes mine from me and then takes
everybody else's and then takes
everyone's call she it's which say like
you know all the names of everything and
that thing times things are happening
and takes them all and I'm like what is
going on I walk outside and she has like
a bonfire she's burning all the scripts
and the call sheets and it turns out
that that someone from princess camp
said like who are the celebrities I hope
it's not a Kardashian I think Khloe
Kardashian Kris Jenner had very kindly
come in yeah shot the scene and then
they were like okay okay like an
animation get out fast
yes about princes coming if he sees you
it's great to be bad they didn't want
anyone to that's by each other yeah
they're used to that don't worry about
it oh I felt so bad because obviously
everyone had gone out of their way to go
there on that day but Prince was running
the shows we we have a clip here from
that episode let's take a look at this
clip from Prince on new girl hi
[Music]
I'm Prince
so it seems to be the problem
how rude of me I haven't given you
enough time to freak out yet you may do
so
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you